Conceptually map and transpose are 1-to-1. Each input maps to a single unique output.
You can think of a gather operation as many-to-1. Many possible inputs can be chosen to compute an output.
In this terminology, scatter is 1-to-many,
so each thread chooses from many possible output destinations.
Stencil can be seen as a specialized gather that pulls output from a select few inputs
in a given neighborhood of the output. So you might turn that to several-to-1.
In the next lecture John will tell you about 2 more really fundamental patterns.
Reduce could be turned all-to-one. For example if you're adding up all the numbers in an array.
Finally scan and sort can be considered all-to-all because
all of the input can affect the destination of the resulting output.
You'll learn more about these in the next lectures.